ab 50 also wenn man die überschreitet da
muss man umfassende schutzmaßnahmen
ergreifen weil man davon ausgehen muss
dass wir in ein exponentielles wachstum
kommen und damit dann auch eines tages
in die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems und unterhalb von 50
gibt es noch die zahl 35 das ist
sozusagen eine vorsicht zahl hat der
mann schon erste schutzmassnahmen machen
soll oder im umkehrschluss wenn man sie
unterschreitet darf man wieder an
größere öffnungs schritte denken ich
will gar nicht drum herum reden es gibt
eine enttäuschung und vielleicht hat
diese enttäuschung etwas damit zu tun
dass ich jetzt erstmal faszinierend fand
dafür überhaupt einen impfstoff haben
nach weniger als einem jahr das ist eine
riesenleistung damit konnte man nicht
rechnen
und dann wir nicht ausreichend darauf
hingewiesen haben dass am anfang nicht
für jeden gleich der impfstoff da ist
man hat sehr große zentren gebaut die
erwartung war im märz wäre diese zentren
ausgelastet sein ende märz april da
werden wir mühe haben alles zu verkaufen
aber die ersten wochen sind jetzt knapp
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren